oui moi un vrai je vous dis la vérité le
mourre c'est mon plan b
moi mon plan a c'est de me faire
kidnapper par les extraterrestres
tous les jours j'y pense en vrai c'est
même pas un kidnapping parce que je suis
trop chaud
c'est le kidnapping le plus facile de
leur vie ils ont même pas besoin de
s'arrêter juste en passant ils
ralentissent la vie de ma mère je
m'accroche
et après ils font ce qu'ils veulent à y
mettre les doigts dans le cul j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] je suis leur salle offre
aux extraterrestres et de savin ils
connaissent mes tétons en wifi dans tout
l'univers je m'en bats les couilles je
suis leur [ __ ] mais tous les jours je
sors de chez moi je regarde le ciel je
suis une [ __ ]
ya pas plus alors que moi ici
après attention je parle vrai
extraterrestre un petit verre les grands
yeux ne m'étais pas des humains avec une
carte je vais me le prendre
moi je veux c'était petit vers les
grands yeux ils sortent du vaisseau tous
les
genres le vaisseau vision penser mais le
slip sait pas encore où
tout nu pas de job
ou à chaque fois qu'il ya un petit extra
terreste dans un film je me dira
peut-être on va boire un petit coup hier
c'est extra terrestrial du tout moi ma
théorie c'est qu'en fait il l'a coincé
derrière comme ça
pour ça ils ont des grands yeux parce
qu'ils sont pas confortables les frérots
en fait c'est ça le truc
pour on n'est pas là pour juger des
traditions
moi mon vrai rêve ce serait mélanger les
deux passions tu vois qu'un jour viendra
il passe au dessus il entend une blague
et se dit [ __ ] mais lui sur jupiter il
peut tout baiser
je pars en tournée neptune pluton tu
imagines tu es sur pluton géant vous
n'êtes même pas une planète bande de
fils de [ __ ]
je vais les fracasser vos meux fait
selon lui aux yeux c'est pas des
lunettes khemed c'est des ruches
je vais les tuer ils vont être là à salo
et
moi
c'est moi